foreign
[Music]
hi guys it's Quinn here if you enjoy my
videos consider hitting the like button
it's the only way the YouTube algorithm
really notices me between demonetization
and just the unstable nature of AD
revenue on YouTube and due to constant
rule changes and increased censorship
YouTube isn't the best place for Content
creators if you want to support the
channel and make sure we stay afloat
consider checking out our patreon we've
got all new perks including access to a
patreon only channel on Discord Early
Access to videos and a once a month
hatron only live stream also 10 and up
patrons get a copy of the ebook and the
audiobook version of my graphic novel
tadia we've got other perks like your
name appearing in videos and also
special roles in the Discord server and
more perks to come check it out thanks
guys
I've been covering the three body
problem book series on this channel for
quite some time now tencent just
released the first four episodes of the
television show adaptation want to know
what I think I'll be reviewing the show
on my new streaming Channel Quinn
streams Link in the description
this video will contain Major Spoilers
for shinlu's remembrance of Earth's past
trilogy
the cosmos and its inhabitants
throughout most of the series remains
mysterious but eventually more about the
nature of the universe and those who
live in it is revealed much of what we
learn only adds to the cosmic dread that
already permeates much of the series
the remembrance of Earth's past Trilogy
by shishin Lu paints a picture of cosmic
civilization that is dark lonely and
terrifying a universe where infant
civilizations on young worlds might call
out into the darkness seeking reprieve
from the seemingly endless Cosmic
loneliness only to find that they have
revealed themselves to a hunter in the
dark whose weapon is now squarely
focused upon them
this is the reality of life within the
Dark Forest but there are some who
Master this universe in this video we
will discuss the various civilizations
and groups known to inhabit shishinlu's
universe
part one Humanity
following the bunker era Shang Xin and
AA were the only humans to survive the
dimension strike on Earth's solar system
after using a spaceship powered by
curvature propulsion they made it to one
of the planets at Star
dx3906 because of the effects of
Relativity several centuries had passed
from the perspective of Earth
while on the world they encounter Guan
Yi than who had been one of the
inhabitants of the vessel blue space
which had fled Humanity's solar system
long before the dimension strike
occurred
from youthan chongxin and AA learn that
Humanity did in fact prosper and there
were several groups of humans living on
several planets throughout the darkness
to understand how Humanity accomplished
this we have to begin with Tian Ming and
his stories which had hidden messages
embedded into them about how to survive
within the Dark Forest
one of the messages involved the
creation of a black domain
a black domain was essentially a region
in space where the speed of light was
lowered significantly to an outside
Observer the space surrounded by a black
domain would appear as an empty region
of space now lowering the speed of light
through a medium was actually possible
but lowering the speed of light through
vacuum was something else entirely the
speed of light through the vacuum of
space was one of the fundamental
constants of the universe to alter the
speed of light was equivalent to
altering the laws of physics which only
the most advanced civilizations within
the Dark Forest were capable of
Research into lowering the speed of
light through the vacuum of space begin
in the bunker era the black domain was
considered as a secondary survival plan
for the human race
tremendous resources were devoted and
even a large-scale space City devoted to
the research of the subject was
constructed in the Saturn cluster it was
named light speed one the creation of
the circum solar particle accelerator
led to the success of the largest
project ever enacted under the black
domain project this was the black hole
project
it was virtually impossible to create a
local gravity field in a laboratory
setting which is why the circum solar
particle accelerator was needed it was
capable of creating microscopic black
holes
the book death's end recounts the life
of a man named way
he was the head of the black hole
project way was a neurodivergent genius
who became obsessed with the project
dedicating himself to the study of the
speed of light due to his neural
Divergence he had extreme trouble with
communicating with other people
because of this he was heavily closed
off from the rest of humanity
way was tortured because of the way he
was he wanted to change himself to love
to laugh to join in on the dance of
humanity
he developed an association between who
he was and the speed of light he thought
that if he could change light speed then
he could change himself
but the speed of light through vacuum
really was the most stable thing in the
cosmos Research into lowering the speed
of light resembled torturing light
without regard for consequences people
tried to do everything with Light Strike
It twist it break it dissect it stretch
it crush it even destroy it but the
result was at most a change in its
frequency in vacuum but the speed of
light remained unchanged like an
unscalable wall
all these decades theoreticians and
experimenters alike were in despair
there was a saying if there really were
a Creator the only thing he welded shut
in all creation was the speed of light
the circum solar particle accelerator as
I mentioned earlier could produce
microscopic black holes but these
evaporated quickly in order to produce a
stable one a microscopic black hole had
to be injected into Jupiter's smallest
Moon letter
letter had an approximate radius of 8
kilometers they were able to lower the
Moon from its high orbit and change its
orbit so that instead it became a body
orbiting the Sun parallel to Jupiter at
the time this was the most massive body
humans had ever moved through space
the microscopic black hole once it was
injected into letter began to rapidly
absorb lettuce mass and grow
the intense radiation generated by
material falling into the black hole
melted the surrounding Rock soon the
eight kilometer radius letter melted
entirely
and The potato-shaped Rock turned into a
red glowing ball of lava the lava ball
shrank slowly but glowed brighter and
brighter until it finally disappeared
with a blinding flash observation showed
that other than a small amount of
material ejected by the radiation most
of the mass of leader had been absorbed
by the black hole
the black hole was stable and its Event
Horizon had grown to 21 nanometers
eventually another space city was
constructed around the black hole this
was deemed light speed too
the black hole itself was suspended in
the middle of light speed too equipment
and Personnel could be brought into
Lightspeed 2 in order to study the black
hole this being the first time human
beings could study a black hole in a
laboratory setting led to many
discoveries which helped in the
development of fundamental cosmology and
theoretical physics
way became infatuated with the black
hole he would often hang against the
protective net surrounding the black
hole staring into it from five
kilometers away
as time went on however he became
frustrated with the lack of progress he
came to despise the laws of nature as
well as fear them
he watched its luminescence like we're
doing now and sometimes claim that the
black hole was talking to him
that he could decipher the message of
its flickering light
eventually way was sucked into the black
hole
he being one of the principal physicist
of the black hole project had the
password to the protective net in order
to get a closer look at the object of
his infatuation he lowered it he then
drifted Beyond The Event Horizon
no one knows whether or not this was an
accident
black holes even outside of Science
Fiction are the strangest objects in the
universe beyond the Event Horizon all
knowledge fails us nothing can escape
even light this means that from the
perspective of those outside the Event
Horizon an object or person would never
actually enter the black hole in death's
end it is not clear what happened to way
from his perspective
under general relativity a distant
Observer would see a clock near the
Event Horizon slow down and the process
of way Falling Towards The Event Horizon
would also slow down and stretch into
Infinity
but within Way's own frame of reference
he had already passed through the Event
Horizon even more oddly the figure's
proportions were normal perhaps it was
because the black hole was so small
but tidal forces did not seem to be at
work he had been compressed into the
nanometer range but space there was also
extremely curved more than one physicist
believed that the body's structure of
whey wasn't harmed at the Event Horizon
in other words he's probably still alive
at this moment
the truth about whether or not we
actually survived was never revealed in
the series
though way would never learn how to
reduce the speed of light the data
gathered from the research of the black
hole would be instrumental in the future
development of curvature propulsion
curvature propulsion would allow vessels
to travel at light speed but as a side
effect they would also produce reduced
speed black holes black domains by the
time shungzine and AA escape the
destruction of Earth's solar system and
traveled to Planet blue in their own
curvature propulsion ship they find that
the descendants of blue space and
gravity who make up nearly all of
humanity have now expanded greatly
independently developing curvature
propulsion and black domains
because Galaxy humans unlike solar
system humans did not have the stories
of Tian mean to help they achieved these
Feats about 200 years later than solar
system humans
Humanity in this era the Galaxy era
inhabited four separate worlds it is
mentioned that Two Worlds were currently
being opened up for settlement by this
point in time humanity had reached a
crucial point in their development as a
cosmic Society they were aware of the
Dark Forest state of the universe they
had created curvature propulsion drives
and they had the ability to hide within
a black domain in case of exposure to
the greater universe
this was actually the fate of one of the
human worlds
something had occurred on world 3 which
caused them to believe that their
world's coordinates had been exposed
their only choice was to turn their
world into a black domain
after they covered themselves in their
shroud which they called a light curtain
it was impossible to send messages back
and forth from that world to others and
no one on the inside could leave
the inhabitants of World 3 said it was a
happy Paradise though I don't know if
they still think that way after the
light tomb was completed it was
impossible for any messages from that
world to reach the outside
but I think people there are pretty
happy for some people safety is the cine
quanon for happiness
it is mentioned in death's end that
there are some humans in the cosmos that
take a rather interesting approach to
life in the universe
by constantly approaching the speed of
light in vessels called ultimate
spaceships they head for the heat death
of the universe
has anyone in the new world thought of
going to the end of the universe of
course five ultimate spaceships have
already been launched
ultimate spaceships
some call them doomsday ships
ultimate spaceships or Doomsday ships
have no particular destination by their
calculations 50 billion years from our
frame of reference would be just 10
years in theirs
this means it would be possible to reach
the end of the universe within a human
lifetime
Humanity made a place for itself in the
dark Forest which is more than countless
others could say
but the future of humanity and the
future of the universe itself remains
uncertain throughout death's end and
throughout the spin-off novel Redemption
of time
this is because there were powerful
forces throughout the cosmos armed with
the power to rip apart space-time
tearing the fabric of reality itself
one of such groups was the zero homers
part two
the zero homers
in the book descend while on planet blue
with Shang Zane in a a guanyu fan
detects the presence of another vessel
on the other world in the system Planet
Gray
when Xiang Xin and Juan yifan flew up to
investigate they found that it had been
the mysterious zero homers who were
known by the physics-breaking death
lines that their ships left in their
wake
the ship approached the coordinates
provided by the monitoring satellite
where five unidentified spacecraft had
landed and then taken off
an had planned to land the shuttle there
and investigate the traces left by the
spacecraft but he and shungxin had not
anticipated that the mysterious visitors
would leave behind such large signs that
they were visible from space
what is that Zhang Xing cried out death
lines youthan recognized them right away
don't get too close he said to the AI he
was referring to the five black lines
one end of each line was connected to
the surface of the planet and the other
end extended into space like five black
hairs growing out of Planet gray each
line stretched higher than Hunter's
orbit
what are they
Trails left by curvature propulsion
those lines are the result of extreme
curvature manipulation the speed of
light within the trails is zero
death lines were the blackest things in
the universe
they present no details other than
exceptional Darkness
they seem to possess no real surface but
somehow they showed clearly against even
the Blackness of space
the book also describes death lines as
the deadest things in the universe
since the light speed within a deathline
was zero every fundamental particle
inside of a deathline was still there
were no vibrations inside deadlines no
movement and nothing could Escape once
it wandered into one a death line though
it did not have a source of gravity was
essentially a black hole
zero gravity black hole anything that
falls in cannot re-emerge ifan picked up
a rock and tossed it towards one of the
deadlines
The Rock disappeared inside the absolute
Darkness
at this point in human history
Humanity's curvature propulsion drives
could never come close to producing the
type of curvature propulsion that would
lead to the partition of deathlines this
was the work of an extremely Advanced
group
Galactic humans had come across these
lines before but they were rare for now
but considering the near Eternal nature
of the universe Chang wonders how long
before these permanent death lines
littered the sky
Zing gazed up at the giant black columns
reaching into space
they lifted up the domed sky and seemed
to turn the universe into a palace of
death
is this the ultimate end for everything
the group that left these death lines
were known by two names to Galactic
humans the zero homers and the resetters
both names referred to the ultimate
mission of this group
the zero homers hope to reduce the
universe to zero Dimensions they believe
that this would trigger the reset of the
cosmos sending the universe back to the
original state of ten Dimensions which
had been degraded over time by the
warring life of the cosmos
Humanity did not know exactly who the
zero homers were it was also not clear
whether they were a group of individuals
of immense intelligence a civilization
or a group of civilizations but their
existence was confirmed
the zero homers want to reset the
universe and return it to the Garden of
Eden
how by moving the hour hand of the clock
past 12. take spatial Dimensions as an
example it's practically impossible to
drag a universe in lower Dimensions back
into higher dimensions
so maybe it's better to work forward in
the other direction
if the universe can be lowered into zero
dimensions and then beyond the clock
might be reset and everything returned
to the beginning
the universe might possess 10
macroscopic Dimensions again
Humanity actually did not know whether
or not the zero Homer's plan was even
possible
humans had witnessed the
two-dimensionalization of
three-dimensional space but they had yet
to see one dimensionalization let alone
zero-dimensionalization
we've never seen one-dimensionalization
but somewhere some zero homers must be
trying no one knows if they've ever
succeeded
Humanity had however found evidence that
some group likely the zero homers had
been also attempting to lower the speed
of light past zero since lowering light
speed compared to attempting to lower
Universal Dimensions was theoretically
easier reducing the speed of light past
zero would theoretically reset and turn
it to its original speed of infinity or
near Infinity Humanity was not privy to
the theories that would suggest that
this would be possible guanyifan in fact
believes that it simply was not possible
that zero light speed was an impassable
wall
zero light speed is absolute death for
all existence
the cessation of all motion under such
conditions the subjective cannot
influence the objective in any way
so how can the hour hand be shifted past
it
I think the zero homers are practicing a
kind of religion
a kind of performance art
we don't know exactly what knowledge the
zero homers possess
we don't know how long they have been
active it could be possible that their
mission has been going on since before
the universe was three-dimensional
it is possible that their calculations
are correct that the Universe can be
reset but it is also possible that
guanyifan is correct that the zero
homers don't have an actual Theory which
suggests that what they are attempting
to do is possible the idea that a highly
Advanced group of beings have succumbed
to a kind of religious thinking that
will only work to destroy the universe
quicker than it would be otherwise is
pretty terrifying but somehow it seems
realistic to me
it is also possible that the zero homers
are simply wrong in their theories
either way their actions will only serve
to speed up the process of the
universe's destruction
part three
the race of singer
once Humanity's location had been
broadcast throughout the Dark Forest it
was only a matter of time before someone
recognized the signs of intelligent life
and acted offensively this was of course
due to the Hostile nature of cosmic
Society I explained this concept in my
video what makes the forest dark
essentially all life that reveals itself
on a cosmic scale is eventually wiped
out by a higher race of beings in the
case of humanity our Solar System's
destructors came in the form of singer's
race
singer was an insignificant member of a
distant alien world they were immensely
powerful singer's job was to analyze
data
his particular job was seen as trivial
and Easy by the other members of his
seed it is mentioned that because of
this members of his seed thought of him
contemptuously
singer understood that what he did was
not important it just filled in the
pieces but it had to be done and the
task was enjoyable
it mentions in the chapter where singer
is introduced that ten thousand grains
of time have passed since his particular
seed left its Homeworld this is
equivalent to eighty thousand years
it is not clear exactly what is meant by
a seed but it seems to refer to singer's
particular group perhaps genetically
familial it is also mentioned that
singer has accumulated the experience of
ten thousand time grains which implies
that he has been alive as long as his
seed has or at least has a way of
inheriting the experience of his
ancestors
singer describes his Homeworld as once
being a place of great joy but now it
was joyless and so was his seed
it is mentioned that the happiness of
his racist past was recorded in songs he
was called singer because as he went
about his assigned job he enjoyed
singing his racist classical songs as it
was one of the few forms of Joy left to
his people it is not exactly clear
however what singing actually means in
the context of singer's race
Throughout the chapter singer refers to
humans and life forms like us as low
entropy beings compared to singer's race
we are unstructured random beings up
until the point in which singer's race
shows up in the series we have only
encountered the might of the
trisolarians whom pale in comparison to
the might of sinker's race
there was of course the unnamed race of
beings who destroyed the trisolaran
Homeworld but their method for the
destruction of trisolaris firing a photo
aid from a ship indicated that they were
also at a lower level of advancement
than singers race
this chapter also introduced the idea
that a hiding Gene and a cleansing Gene
exist among the life forms of the
universe
this seems to refer to the inclinations
of certain civilizations to hide
themselves from the greater universe and
the inclination to offensively destroy
threatening civilizations
singer's race seems to be
extraordinarily ancient
singer Muse is that in the distant age
lower entropy clusters like Earth's
solar system were rare and far apart
singers race had the capability to
identify signals sent out by intelligent
civilizations and Destroy them with ease
the main core allowed them to do this
the main core's job was to pick up the
coordinates and it remembers all the
positions of the Stars
by matching the received data against
various map projections and the position
schema it could pick out the coordinates
of the messages origin it was said that
the main core could match the position
of schema from 500 million time grains
ago
to singers World below entropy
civilization like the human race who did
not possess the hiding Gene was
dangerous this is because without the
hiding gene they would not be afraid of
exposing their own presence and would
expand an attack without fear
singer's ultimate Choice was to unleash
a dual Vector foil to flatten the
Earth's solar system into two Dimensions
he did this while singing
there's a lot of mysteries surrounding
singer's race more details about them
are presented in the spin-off novel
Redemption of time but I want to keep
this video in the main series we will
cover the events of redemption of time
in another video
part 4. the higher dimensional
microcosmos
the book The three-body problem
introduces a rather mind-boggling
concept
the trisolarins when attempting to
unfold a subatomic particle into two
Dimensions encountered intelligent life
within the particle
when viewed from the vantage point of
higher dimensions a subatomic particle
could be exponentially vast
the princess was one of the few who kept
calm he asked the science Council
how complicated can the internal
structure of a subatomic particle be
it depends on the number of dimensions
of your observation perspective from a
one-dimensional perspective it's only a
point that is how ordinary people think
of the particles from a two or
three-dimensional perspective the
particle begins to show internal
structure from a four-dimensional
perspective a fundamental particle is an
immense world
the princess said to use a word like
immense to describe a subatomic particle
such as a proton seems incredible to me
the science Council ignored the princess
and continued as we move to higher
Dimensions the complexity and number of
structures within a particle increased
dramatically
the comparisons I'm about to make will
not be precise but should give you an
idea of the scale
a particle seen from a seven-dimensional
perspective has a complexity comparable
to our trisolarin Stellar system in
three dimensions from an
eight-dimensional perspective a particle
is a vast presence like the Milky Way
when the perspective has been raised to
nine dimensions a fundamental particle's
internal structure and complexity are
equal to the whole universe
as for even higher Dimensions our
physicists haven't been able to explore
them so we cannot yet imagine the degree
of complexity
considering the complexity of the
internal structure of the proton within
higher Dimensions intelligent life
within one was not only possible but
likely and what the trisolarians
encountered after attempting this first
was undoubtedly intelligent life it
initially manifested in a form that most
intelligent life would recognize
eyes many eyes hovering in the sky above
trisolaris the princess pointed to the
Giant Eyes in space
do these show that the microcosmos
contained within the unfolded proton
Harbors intelligent life
our definition of life is probably not
appropriate for the high dimensional
microcosmos more accurately we can say
that Universe contains intelligence or
wisdom
at first the trisolarin snake that
perhaps the eyes simply wished to
demonstrate their presence these beings
while normally confined to the
microcosmos of the proton within higher
dimensional space were now manifesting
in three dimensions but the trisolarins
were wrong initially this wasn't to
demonstrate their existence this was to
mount an attack on trisolaris who they
obviously rightfully viewed as a threat
to their own microcosmos the eyes
floating above trisolaris merged into
one giant eye and then transform into a
parabolic mirror used to Scorch the
surface of trisolaris
the parabolic Mira focused the sun's
beams onto the surface of trisolaris
initially the spot of light was very
large and the Heat at the focal point
wasn't yet lethal this spot moved across
the ground searching for its Target the
mirror discovered the capital the
largest city of trisolaris and the light
spot began to move toward it soon the
beam was over the city those standing
under the pendulum Monument only saw a
great brightness in space it overwhelmed
everything else accompanied by a wave of
extreme heat then the light spot over
the capital shrink as the parabolic
mirror began to focus the light more
tightly
the brightness from space grew stronger
until no one could lift up his head and
those standing within the spot felt the
temperatures rise rapidly just as the
heat became unbearable the edge of the
light spot swept past the pendulum
monument and everything dimmed it took a
while before the crowd's sight
readjusted to normal light when they
looked up the first sight that greeted
them was a pillar of Light Between the
sky and Earth shaped like an inverted
cone the mirror in space formed the base
of the cone and the tip stabbed the
heart of the capital turning everything
there incandescent at once waves of
smoke begin to rise tornadoes caused by
the uneven heat of the light cone formed
on several pillars made of dust that
connected the sky twisting and dancing
around the light cone
the trisolarins respond in kind
attacking the eye with nuclear warheads
the resulting Devastation leads to the
annihilation of the entire microcosmos
one of near infinite microcosmoses
throughout the Universe
it was at least an intelligent body also
princeps we destroyed the entire
microcosmos
that miniature universe is immense in
higher dimensions and probably contain
more than one intelligence or
civilization that never had a chance to
express themselves in macro space of
course in higher dimensional space at
such a micro scale the forms that
intelligence or civilization may take is
beyond our imagination there's something
else entirely and such Destruction has
probably occurred many times before
oh in the long history of scientific
progress how many protons have been
smashed apart in accelerators by
physicist how many neutrons and
electrons probably no fewer than 100
million every Collision was probably the
end of the civilizations and
intelligences in a microcosmos in fact
even in nature the destruction of
universes must be happening at every
second for example through the decay of
neutrons also a high energy cosmic ray
entering the atmosphere May destroy
thousands of such miniature universes
as I said it is clear that the life
formed within the protons microcosmos
viewed the trisolarins as a threat it is
not clear whether this was a single
civilization within the microcosmos or a
collection of them working together in
defense of their own universe
what is clear is that in the process of
attempting to unfold a proton the
trisolaran sacrificed potentially
trillions of lives
I find this concept very intriguing
whenever it pops up within science
fiction the idea that our universe is
filled with countless smaller universes
within it makes the universe feel even
more vast and infinite than it already
does it also makes us wonder what if our
own Universe was simply a microcosmos
within another grander Universe our
entire Cosmos could potentially be
destroyed at the whim of a greater
civilization within a higher realm of
existence
part five
the trisolaran destructors
during the war with Humanity the
trisolaran sent two separate fleets
towards the Earth's solar system the
initial slower trisolaran fleet was lost
forever to human history
the second trisolaran Fleet however
has a fate that is known to all those
who notice the Interstellar dust cloud
that was the result of their destruction
the second trisolarin Fleet which
contained the most powerful and fastest
ships ever built by the trisolarins
before the destruction of their
Homeworld encountered something
immensely powerful and immensely
destructive presumably while in search
of a new Homeworld somewhere in the
galaxy
we don't know much the first and second
trisolarian fleets never joined together
more than 60 years ago there was a
large-scale space battle near Taurus
it was brutal and the resulting wreckage
formed a new Interstellar dust cloud
we know that one of the sides in the
battle was the second trisolarin Fleet
but we don't know who they were fighting
against we also don't know how the
battle ended
my guess is that the second trisolaran
fleet was annihilated
the trisolarians were powerful but
probably not powerful enough to contend
with whatever they faced out there
up until this point in the series we
have seen multiple examples of
trisolarean technology and weaponry
none of which seemed powerful enough to
create an Interstellar dust cloud as the
result of its destructive capability
it could potentially have been
technology that they developed later on
but I think this is unlikely
the trisolerance at this point seemed to
have not found a suitable home world
technological development for them
aboard a space Fleet would have been
limited compared to if they had a
Homeworld full of resources
so I think it stands to reason that if
they didn't have such powerful
technology before they turned away from
Earth's solar system then they wouldn't
have had it by the time they encountered
whatever destroyed them
though I believe the second trisolaran
fleet was annihilated by a more powerful
alien group I do not think this was the
end of the trisolaran race
though Humanity never learns what became
of the First trisolarian Fleet it is
implied that they went on to perhaps
inhabit new worlds and in the end left
their Mark upon the cosmos
at the end of death's end the
trisolarins like humanity and many
others are called together to restore
the stolen pieces of the universe and
save the cosmos from Ultimate
Destruction
this of course indicates that the First
trisolarin Fleet like the humans of blue
space and gravity bred civilizations
that survived long term in the cosmos
conclusion
one thing that all those who Master the
cosmos seem to share is their ability
and willingness to stay well hidden the
first step in long-term survival in the
cosmos is to hide from all potential
threats meaning all outside
civilizations
it seems that those who Master the
universe are also distinguished in two
types
Those Who hide and cleanse and those who
simply hide
Those Who hide and cleanse not only
shielded themselves well from Outsiders
but took the initiative to eliminate
potential threats before they became a
problem because the so-called cleansing
Gene exists in so many civilizations
Cosmic Society is naturally hostile to
all those who make themselves known
this seems to be a dark truth of the
universe throughout most of the series
that is until the very end of death's
end
the ending of death's end seems to
suggest that cooperation between worlds
will be the only way to save the
universe from collapse and bring about
the adenic age once again it is not
clear exactly who called this Gathering
or how they gathered the names of so
many civilizations in a universe where
hiding was a method for survival
the ending of death's end is shockingly
optimistic suggesting that even with the
harsh reality of cosmic life the
ultimate solution could be the joining
together of different civilizations
we will cover these events and the
events leading up to them in death's end
in a future video
okay so now it's time to answer patreon
questions no not again what are you
talking about organism 9186 this is the
first time we've done this and we're
going to be doing it a lot more now that
my patreon has all new perks okay so
first question
is the 10 cent series only focused on
the first book as far as I can tell it
definitely is I'm on episode 9 now and
they're really taking their time they've
even added scenes and expanded minor
characters and added whole new
characters there's 30 episodes total so
they're really not gonna have to drop
any details from that first book and I
think that's a good thing ultimately
next question greetings for context I've
only just started reading the first
novel of the three body problem series
and watch the tints and adaptation
through episode 4. do you have any
thoughts as to why so many scientists
responded to the physics not being real
with committing suicide
well first off I think you should finish
reading the book because there are
certain Revelations that make things
make a lot more sense and I actually
think it's a little bit more clear in
the tense and adaptation with the added
scenes now you're probably not going to
be able to hear the answer to your own
question if you don't want to be spoiled
but for everybody else that's listening
I'll go ahead the trisolarins are
essentially already on Earth or at least
they're super computers aka the sofons
these super computers are what is making
physics not work properly and these
supercomputers are the way in which
trisolaris communicate with ETO the
Earth trisolaris organization which has
essentially infiltrated the frontiers of
science or maybe the frontiers of
science is simply a front for ETO it's a
little bit vague in the book essentially
the frontiers of science locates
important scientists around the world
who are doing important work it quote
unquote recruits them and then begins to
psychologically manipulate them we see
this happening with Wang in the book and
in the show
and the show also gives us examples of
it happening to other people directly
with the use of the so funds ETO can
project images right onto the eyeballs
of their victims essentially ETO is
driving them to Suicide well that's
pretty dark yeah organism I mean
shishinlu is not playing around it's
pretty dreary
alright moving on to our next patreon
question which is kind of related g'day
Quinn I'll make an assumption here that
you're referring to the first novel for
your questions and not the series
remembrance of first pass as a whole I
would like to know your views on ETO
Earth trisolaris organization and what
it is in some detail in particular are
they a fifth column supporting The
Invasion are they a cult are they just
capitalists looking to exploit the
situation are they all of the above and
more well Donovan this is a great great
question I probably should do an entire
video on ETO so ETO as you mentioned
stands for Earth trisolaris organization
it was founded by ya wenji who was the
person who initially alerted the
trisolarians of Earth's location in
space
essentially
ETO supports the trisolarin invasion but
there are also different factions within
ETL it's been around for several decades
by the start of the book and things have
changed since its initial conception so
there are three main factions within ETO
you've got the survivors they hope that
by selling out the rest of humanity that
they and their children their offspring
will be granted special privileges and
spared from the worst of what the rest
of humanity will get and then there are
the Adventists they are the closest to
what ETO originally stood for and they
just straight up hate the human race
they want to see it destroyed
and then finally the most interesting
group The redemptionist they have formed
a kind of religion based on the
trisolarians they see them as a superior
species
the redemptionist main thing is trying
to solve the three-body problem itself
trying to figure out a way to predict
the movement of the three sons of
trisolaris optimally they hope that by
doing so trisoleras can just stay in
their own system and not come to Earth
and then later in the books we've of
course got the wall breakers but we will
get into that in the future I would
definitely make a dedicated video on ETO
later on well I should start the Earth
troll Leon organization you know I'd
love to see you try at organism9186
everyone should seek out their own
dreams
anyway next question I'm curious about
your thoughts on the VR scenes as well
as the glimpse of the trisolarin world I
assume you're talking about the tencent
TV show I really enjoyed the episode
that showed the game for the first time
it was neat to see that sequence
realized that's such an awesome trippy
part in the book and I think the tencent
show holds up pretty well even though
it's a little bit different as far as
the glimpses of Tri Solaris that we've
gotten so far throughout the show we
haven't seen very much but everything's
been pretty cool looking if you want
more details about what I think about
the tencent show I'm going to be
streaming all about it as the show
continues to air on my new streaming
Channel Queen streams you can subscribe
to that channel if you want to catch all
of those live streams alright looks like
that's the last of our questions let's
go get some ice cream organism yay I
love ice cream
so we've got some great news guys
Quinn's ideas officially has a Discord
now my goal is to make this Discord a
great place for all science fiction fans
to come and talk about science fiction
share their favorite books share their
love of science fiction stories and
Concepts while having a lot of fun I'm
really excited about this new way to
engage with my community and to create
more connectivity between my viewers I
hope you will join us over on Discord
thank you so much
just a heads up for those of you that
may be interested my next graphic novel
the LIE behind the star is launching
February 2023 you can sign up now to get
on the email mailing list to get
notified as soon as it launches more
information on my website link in the
description thank you guys so much
[Music]
foreign